bird box Netflix's terrifying journey
into a world where you can't trust your
eyes is packed with intriguing little
details that you'll be thinking about
long after the credits have rolled
let's break down those little details
and what they might mean as we unpack
the movies ending one of the most
frightening things about Byrd box is how
little it tells us about what's really
happening to the world specifically
regarding the mysterious creatures
plaguing humanity we know that from a
mere glance that can drive most people
to suicide and some people to madness
but why little rel Howery character
Charlie suggests that the creatures are
demons feeding on Souls somehow
sustaining themselves by devouring
people's sanity but that theory is never
proven leaving much of the creatures
nature and what people see when they
look at them up to the audience's
imagination another part of the puzzle
the creatures pose involves where
exactly they came from and why they
arrived
we're told the creatures emergence began
in Eastern Europe before crossing into
the United States but that's all we get
to go on they could be extraterrestrial
creatures biological weapons or
spiritual demons all answers seem
equally likely did you learn all of that
working at the supermarket the creatures
unknown motives drive the movies mystery
leaving the characters with no clue what
they're up against the threat is almost
beyond description which is where the
movie gets most of its horror some
questions the characters have to
consider is do the creatures reproduce
is there a finite number of them or will
they just keep coming
just how screwed is planet Earth if the
protagonists knew the source of the
monsters they'd be better equipped to
fight back instead all they can rely on
is their own Gessler when Mallory and
the children which she calls boy and
girl finally arrive at rick's compound
down the river they discover that it's a
school for the blind complete with a
bird sanctuary that serves as a kind of
early warning system for the compounds
sighted residents it seems to be a
secure system although it does have some
troubling implications for the future of
humanity if this is the status quo in
the world right now and these creatures
will never truly go away does that give
blind people a genetic advantage for the
future of the human race if Rick and his
students survived other communities of
blind people likely did as well the
implication is that sightless people are
the only
who have a chance at thriving and living
on in a world plagued by these monsters
for people who enjoy being able to see
the world that's a pretty frightening
thought
unfortunately the creatures aren't the
only thing that the people in bird box
have to worry about there's also the
creatures human acolytes who are all
bent on exposing everyone to the
creatures that they can depending on who
you talk to these people were either
already insane when they saw the
creatures or were driven insane by
contact with them but in the wake of
this contact they remain alive and very
dangerous they're not insane in the
sense that they are incapable of
rational behavior they can give the
appearance of being reasonable carry on
conversations and deceive people
implying something more nuanced than
mere madness if these people are so
convinced that everyone should see the
creatures it stands to reason that they
would choose to reproduce and show their
children as well potentially raising a
whole generation of people who find the
creatures beautiful it could all set up
a strange future society in which
humanity is divided into two very
different sides one trying their hardest
not to look at the creatures and another
trying to expose them to the world
Rick's compound is a school for the
blind meaning the majority of the people
there when the outbreak began were
people who simply couldn't be influenced
by the creatures strange ability to
drive people who see the mad it's a
clever plot development and it makes
sense in the context of what we know
about the creatures but what about the
other way is the creatures can influence
humans we see during the grocery store
run that they're able to rock the car
which means they can affect the world in
a physical way and even when Mallory
isn't looking at them they're able to
get inside her head and tempt her with
the voices of dead people can they do
the same to the blind do they get
stronger as they influence more people
are the blind people truly safe in this
world or can the creatures ultimately
find a way to influence them - only time
will tell the bird box of the film's
title refers in a literal sense - the
cardboard box Mallory uses to store her
birds for the journey down the river
using the sensitive little birdies as an
alarm system for when the creatures are
their followers or near in a
metaphorical sense though the bird box
can be seen as Mallory's own hearts
tensed up and locked away while she
simply tries to survive the horrors of
her life when they finally arrive at the
school for the blind one of Mallory's
first acts of relief and comfort is to
open the box and release the birds to be
with their friends and shortly after
that she finally softens with her
children giving them real names as a
sign that they're now about to live a
better life throughout the film we see
Mallory's growth as a leader as a mother
and as a survivor and now she's found a
place where she doesn't have to be so
harsh all the time as a means of staying
alive well that strong sense of
leadership continue to be with her in
times of crisis or will she continue to
soften and get her humanity back more
likely she'll just have to find a
balance as she works for a new way
forward with her fellow survivors the
ending may be happy enough for her and
her children
but as for the fate of the rest of the
world well it really just doesn't look
good
[Music]